mind your decisions presh tal Walker
here the American Invitational
mathematics examination or Amy for short
is a qualifying test in America for the
International mathematical Olympiad
it's a three-hour test that involves 15
questions and calculators are not
allowed every answer is a whole number
from 0 to 999 inclusive in this video
we'll cover problem 7 from the 1984 exam
the function f is defined on the
integers and satisfies f of n is equal
to n minus 3 if n is greater than or
equal to a thousand and it's equal to f
of f of n plus 5 if n is less than 1000
the question is what is f of 84 I think
Henry from the Phillipines for
suggesting this problem pause the video
if you'd like to give it a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve this problem
[Music]
so if you're like me you try to solve
this problem by directly calculating f
of 84 since 84 is less than a thousand
this is equal to f of f of 89 since 89
is less than a thousand this is equal to
F of F of F of 94 if you try working
this direction a little further it feels
like you're trying to open a Russian
doll each time you're trying to simplify
the problem you end up with a copy of
the problem and it doesn't seem to be
getting any simpler it just seems to be
getting more and more nested and
eventually you're not getting anywhere
so sometimes when you try and solve a
problem you end up with a dead end but
don't despair try another approach
rather than directly trying to calculate
f of 84 let's try working from the other
direction
let's try calculating for values around
a thousand what is f of 999 by
definition this is equal to F of F of
1004 now by definition F of 1004 is
equal to n minus 3 which is 1001 now we
applied the definition once more and we
get the answer of 998 we'll do a similar
thing to calculate F of 998 we applied
the definition of F and we end up with
997
let's try working out a few more
examples what's F of 997 while we work
through the definition of F and we get
to F of 999 luckily we've just
calculated that this is equal to 998 we
can do a similar calculation for F of
996 we get to F of 998 and this is equal
to 997 let's calculate a few more what's
F of 995 we work through the definition
and we get to F of 997 which is equal to
998 F of 995
or will be equal to F of 998 and that's
equal to 997 so we see a pattern
emerging for values less than 8,000 F of
an odd number is equal to 998 and F of
an even number is equal to 997 you can
prove this by induction ultimately we
get that F of 84 since 84 is an even
number will be equal to 997 and that's
our answer
now I just want to do a little extension
for fun this problem can actually be
solved very elegantly and very simply
using computer code now I know it's a
problem from a 1984 exam but we can
actually use modern computer code like
Python to solve this very quickly so we
wanted to find a function dull of n if n
is greater than or equal to a thousand
we want to get the value of n minus 3
otherwise we want to get the value of F
of F of n plus 5 this will be written as
return doll of doll of n plus 5 and this
is something pretty interesting we're
defining the function doll in terms of
the function doll this is an example of
recursion and we'll use it to solve this
problem now you just type in this code
and then type in print the value of doll
of 84 and you'll get the answer of 997
instantly it's amazing that Python can
solve this problem so quickly and all
you need to do is type in the definition
of the function so this is a great
problem from a 1984 test and the problem
can illustrate the power of computer
code
thanks for being the best subscribers on
YouTube thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]